There's really not much you need to do to get
your application to use Memcache to save and get entity data,
if you're using Objectify. But it's still useful to know
how to write code to use Memcache. So we're going to use
Memcache to save and get announcements, about conferences that are
nearly sold out. You can imagine, for example, that your web
app might display a banner ad to encourage people to
sign up. For conferences that are nearly sold out. There might
be other things you want to announce on your website, too.
Maybe if you get a special speaker for a particular conference.
Or you want to announce a special promotion. But for the
sake of simplicity, we're just going to create announcements that conferences
are nearly sold out. Because the goal here is to learn
how to use Memcache. Announcements though, are a good example of
the kind of thing that you might want to save in
Memcache, without saving them to the Datastore. If the announcement gets evicted
from Memcache, there's no loss of real data, and it
doesn't really matter. No business transactions are affected, no one loses
their place at a conference. And the next announcement will likely
come along very soon anyway. Announcements are very transient, and don't
need to be saved for the long term and they
don't need to be backed up. So, they're perfect candidates to
be saved in Memcache, and only in Memcache. They don't need
to into the Datastore, that way you get all your announcements
without using any quota. So, you're going to
adding the announcement class to your project. It's
a very simple class, we need it because
n point functions can't return string objects. So
they're going to put the text for the announcement,
in the message field. Note that this class
is not annotated as our entity. We don't
want to save the announcements in the data store.